thank you for meeting with channel 8 to
discuss the world changer scholarship
that you offer at Hamilton and Manuela
orthodontics so we're here with both dr.
Hamilton and dr. Manuel II I hear that
you are approaching your fourth year of
offering this scholarship can you please
tell us a little bit about it absolutely
so the the world-changers scholarship it
started about four years ago and we
wanted to find a way to acknowledge what
some especially youth in the community
are doing to make a difference and to
make a positive impact and so we start a
scholarship and we heard that with a
calendar and so each year we search for
youth who are doing amazing things
around our community to make a
difference and we highlight them not
only with a scholarship but also with
recognition as as part of being part of
our annual calendar wonderful did you
have anything to add that to that as
well dr. Hamilton rocky what what I
really like about the scholarship is
it's just a continuation of who we are
and what we try to do we're in a
profession where we get to change
people's smiles and and and that changes
their lives but we find that they have
so much more to offer and when they go
out and do something that they have more
confidence and they can tackle the
things in life and reach for higher
goals that really just warms our heart
and we want more of that and if we can
facilitate it in some way I would say
the scholarship is just a continuing
effort on our part to help change
people's lives for the better and the
amazing thing that we find out about it
is we actually get more out of it than
the recipients so it's definitely a
win-win-win so we're looking for
applications for from students in any
student from kindergarten on up to a
senior in high school is is to our
primary audiences for the scholarship
and we've been impressed and amazed at
some of our younger applicants you know
kids in in grade school that are have
gone out of their way to make huge
differences in the community and
you don't have to be a senior in high
school getting ready to go to college it
can be anybody k12 can apply we've
always felt like there's everybody can
contribute and so we we want every
person that we meet or any applicant no
matter how large or how small that a
contribution it's it's kind of a it's an
effort by everyone if everyone can just
do their part it makes the world a
better place and so I would never want
anyone not to apply because they feel
they're not good enough or whatever
they're doing is not significant because
as we know every little bit helps we
wouldn't want anyone to think that their
contribution isn't great enough to apply
for our scholarship everybody can do
something
and no matter how large or how small it
often makes a much bigger difference
than you think so please apply where
where can we go to learn more
information about this program so the
best place to go is to our website so
that would be W WH AM ortho comm and
then you can just click on the world
changer link and there is it will take
you directly to the online application
where you can apply what made you decide
to start the world change your program
our scholarship dr. C why don't you
start on that and then all I in whenever
well first first of all rocky we're in a
great profession orthodontics is just an
amazing profession where we get to
change people's smiles and make them
feel a little more self-confident and
when you go dig a little deeper you
often get reminded that you're you're
literally changing their lives and then
they get to change the world and to be a
part of that we just felt like what can
we do to to get more of that and feel
more of that great feeling and so the
scholarship kind of was born out of that
so to speak when I was when I was young
I needed braces and one of the things
that I've always appreciated was that my
orthodontist took the time to explain
being with me and and specifically I
knew that
I knew that they believed I could do
everything that I needed to do to get a
great smile and so in the practice we
try to instill some belief especially in
our younger patient population that they
can do great things that they are great
that they're amazing
and if we can help them to believe that
about themselves we know that they're
going to continue to make a huge
difference whatever they apply
themselves to throughout their lives and
so we wanted to bring recognition bring
validity and bring really confidence to
these kids to help them to do those
great things which they want to do in
which they can do being an orthodontist
it's really a privilege to be able to do
what we do and we get reminded daily
that we're changing people's smiles and
improving them but but every once in a
while we get feedback that were actually
changed in their lives and that really
makes us feel good so we want more of
that and we've the scholarship was born
out of that how can we help young people
change the world and thus make us and
everyone else feel good about where we
are and what we do thank you so much for
joining channel eight and we look
forward to sharing this on our website
so for more information visit eight News
now.com and we will also link to the
scholarship application on our website
thank you for joining us today dr.
manolio dr. Hamilton